I went to Sephora this weekend okay you
know get some skincare with Elena okay
and I'm afraid
oh you're going for yourself yeah oh
okay all right get some skincare I'm not
judging honestly I I'm just that's
probably the only yeah I want to do that
next time yeah I've never enjoyed
a Sephora trip because it always ends up
being me standing there for two hours
yeah I mean it's pretty overwhelming in
there too it is it's all the lights and
God damn I don't I
a million brands in that [ __ ] oh yeah
how do you and a million different
celebs yeah endorsing each other yeah
which one do you like the most JLo's ass
crack is every other
yeah it's just
her poking it out selling what uh I
don't know [ __ ] skinny tea
yeah butt crack cream yeah exactly no
butt crack like blush yeah it's like
crack uh what's the [ __ ] [ __ ] that
goes right here glow yeah no keep going
that's wonderful that's like shiny
eyeshadow no
highlighter it's crack highlighter there
you go yeah yeah the ladies are going
crazy for that right there you know when
JLo be selling butt crack highlighter
yeah yeah Sephora be like Sephora would
be like give me some makeup for my tits
here that makes my tits look bigger
that's what Sephora's like
yeah dude so what were you getting
I ain't no lip plumper
lip gloss he's popping that [ __ ] yeah
dick blush yep all the good stuff ball
plumper
rubbing it on
after Ludwig's nuts got leaked yeah what
happened with that he pulled his nuts
out on cold ones to just be funny and
then uh Chad misunderstood in the edit
like he was like you want him blurred
and then he said he said LOL yeah and
but I think Chad read it like sarcasm
so it was like dude you're a [ __ ]
Legend
and then the nuts came out
so okay so it wasn't like
with bad intentions no no no okay he
actually like mistook his meaning for a
long yeah yeah
because I would have read that as like
oh he wants his nuts censored yeah what
anyone would have read it that way yeah
I see yeah I mean so you know I can't
speak to what Chad was thinking but
whatever funny it's definitely funny so
what happened though he was like I mean
you know just Ludwig's just been yeah
those were my nuts
I mean the the res isn't that high yeah
it just looks like a like a smooth egg
to slip out of his [ __ ] pants I know
what Ludwig's nuts look like now yeah I
mean I was reading he had some big ass
nuts
yeah what yeah everyone's saying he's
got some big balls good for him yeah
yeah Charlie did a video and was like I
feel like I pulled my nuts out and they
they wouldn't look like that at all
just look like [ __ ] just you know
just like Harry dates yeah
what was that that bacon
is this [ __ ] uncooked what's going on
those are balls right there yeah like
furry dates
if I pulled my nuts out everyone will be
trying to figure out what race I am yeah
yeah exactly
hey look at them dark nuts I know what
he is
this wait a minute this doesn't help at
all yeah this actually makes it way
harder those nuts are vague some vague
ass nuts right there
you got dark nuts what's up
I've never seen your ball so I don't
know we may never know dude yeah no my
my nuts are [ __ ]
my nuts are [ __ ] vanta black
okay you ever seen that car paint no
there's like no light refracts off of it
yeah my [ __ ] just looks like a comic
book cover you look into it you just see
the stars you're like what is happening
is that a black hole Yeah is there even
matter there yeah is that anti-matter
yeah I'll just pull my nuts out and
someone would be like I think the editor
[ __ ] up there's like a weird track mat
going on
you wrote out his balls that's
impressive that's so cool I have to do
that [ __ ]
yeah man mine are salmon colored that's
cool man
really glad we know that now
things I didn't want to know for
200 bucks
Cody's salmon nuts no they're not I just
feel like that's the worst color yeah
yeah salmon yeah
anyway so what do you think about Elon
on Twitter right now oh we get into that
but hold on I had to tell my dad joke
that I delivered a Sephora oh yeah sorry
yeah
I'm also just thinking about how many
celebs really are at every stall
yeah I mean it's like
yeah anyone you could possibly
anyone that anyone else looks up to is
there selling a product yeah butt crack
highlighter yeah I bet you that exists
you know summer is coming back make sure
your butt crack make sure your crack is
make sure your crack is creamed
keep your crack moisturized with JLo's
new uh moisturizer it's the booty
moisturizer that keeps your crack silky
smooth
pop your [ __ ] yeah at Sephora yeah when
I go to the beach in the summer I like
my butt crack smooth yeah smooth as ice
I don't know if ice is smooth but yeah
no so we were returning some [ __ ]
because I bought some sunscreen and
every time I put it on you know I just
look like a
you know people who are just like have
skin conditions where they're violently
afraid of the Sun so they just put on so
much sunscreen yeah the white cast is
crazy I was basically doing like white
face like James Charles like it just
wasn't soaking in yeah I look like James
Charles like that meme
oh my dude gotta take this back and
Elena had to exchange some [ __ ] so we go
there
we're about to do the exchange and then
uh so you you went to Sephora to buy it
and then you went back to return it yep
damn I mean I didn't go solo right you
know yeah I got to use my lady as my
shield she's the reason I'm there yeah
but also yeah I'm not yeah she's the
reason I'm not yeah
I'm not shopping here yeah yeah although
you maybe you can buy like Brad Pitt's
stuff there no can you I don't think he
has anything isn't that yeah he does
he's got like a skincare line now oh
that's like targeted at men I didn't see
it in there I just saw Jay Lewis ask
Craig nice
and uh so we're returning one of the
items and the girl goes
so uh were you returning this one as
well I was like yeah
like a [ __ ] dad I go yeah it didn't
taste very good
and then she go she kind of she kind of
laughed when she she she's kind of
focused on whatever and then Elena
starts diving she's like you're dumb as
hell and then I start laughing really
hard that I have to look away I just
thought about what if I was the town guy
I just show up there like once a week I
buy crazy amounts of makeup like what's
up with dudes like oh look at his teeth
and they're just like stained look at
the makeup
like
I'm just getting the eye palettes and
busting them out and eating them in
front of the store
that's so good
you're like didn't taste very good and
she's like uh-huh you're like what's
funny yeah it didn't
this one takes tastes horrible yeah
dinner at Sephora yeah
buying perfume and drinking it
it's so stupid
oh that's really funny they're like
estimate that's the makeup eating guy
you're coming your teeth song like
I thought of that because I hate the
crack highlighter it tastes good that's
my favorite one so far
why is it for your butt crack it's good
on your teeth
looks good when I [ __ ] it out
yeah dude so you know
I had butt crack highlighter cereal this
morning
[Laughter]
funny joke it's not a joke what's funny
it didn't taste good
it tastes like batteries it's just just
stand in front of the store with a hot
dog just sprinkling highlighter
other [ __ ] on it just dude just an
SPF just squirting it on like [ __ ]
ketchup
yeah running outside of Sephora you
can't wait to get outside tearing The
Box open and trying to kill the little
things
you're like holy [ __ ]
it's the Haley Bieber cream
yeah that's gonna be that's gonna be
2030 when there's no water left yeah and
be eating Sephora products and
anything with substance in it
damn